hey guys bradley here from some sub just
stopping by to wish you a wonderful
christmas hope you're doing some nice
things with your family maybe some
smoked salmon scrambled egg and bucks
fizz right now is this per the tradition
in the uk uh anyway we're not uploading
a video today unfortunately but you will
be seeing lucas next week so don't fret
it does give you a bit of an opportunity
to revisit some of our older videos for
instance the cicada one is quite good
and also quite long i know that you
probably will get a lot of time today so
go and check that out also if you're
doing some last minute shopping don't
forget about security don't use public
wi-fi without a vpn right you might
consider a virtual credit card right for
purchases and don't trust any of those
big discounts anyway happy holidays hope
you have a wonderful new year if i don't
see you before then um and we've got
some big things planned so stay tuned
and thanks for your support